foreign
ly you will hear that the squatter was
flirting with me asking to take me out
on a date asking to buy me dinner
because he said that that will make up
for the energy that he's used at the
property like the theft of gas and
electricity and stuff and then he
started asking me how old I was and it
was just getting really inappropriate
and
um he started saying that if I saw him
in real life I'd never you know I'd
never guess that he's a squatter
[Music]
hi we are Leah and AK also known as
property couple and we document property
investing business and working together
as a couple on YouTube and we've been
doing it for about three and a half
years now
it was January of this year and we got a
message through to us and from somebody
who drove past the property and there
was a big letter up on the door
and um I was away working and you were
on holiday weren't you and um this
picture come through and it was a letter
from the squatter to us so it's them
saying like I've moved in here I've been
living here from the 16th of January and
at this point it was now like the 23rd
of January so I just started panicking
like oh my gosh we'd been waiting for
this property to receive planning
permission so that's why it was vacant
so I was on the phone to the police and
um they said the only way we can go to
the property is if he's committed an
offense and I've obviously
Googling everything and I found out that
theft of utilities without the owner's
consent is an offense so I was like
right they can go there for that so I
sent I asked the police to go there and
they did whilst the police were there
they said look your squatters are out
right now they asked me if they could
force entry to the property we gave
permission for them to four centuries
this property is about three hours away
from where we live
and the police was going around and the
policeman was walking around the
property and he was like there's a lot
of food here mattress air fryer they set
up an air fryer in the house they had
set up a TV they had unplugged our
landline phone and plugged it in next to
the bed like it was a Holiday Inn like
they'd also disconnected the fire alarm
system So that obviously you know nobody
was notified it because the squatter was
like smoking in the property and stuff
so he kind of like ripped out the fire
alarm system it started tampering with
the electrics and it also started
ripping out pipe work and selling off us
selling off our stuff as like scrap
metal presumably for money
so there was all this going on and then
I said to the policeman okay where does
this leave me right now because he's not
at the property the squatter is not
there and the policeman said it's very
rare for squatters to leave because they
know that if an owner comes they
technically you can get them out by
locking them out
so we quickly called around and we found
a local Builder to go and drop
everything on his current project and go
and
um like secure our property and like
nail down every door they secured the
property so well that even we were
locked out the property everyone was
locked out of the Roti every window was
screwed shut just as a temporary fix and
then we found out that we couldn't
actually throw out all of the squatters
stuff like the mattress and the food and
the airfryer and everything because then
we'd be committing an offense by
throwing out the squatters stuff so
there's a further legal matter here of
what to do with their stuff
so that's why we left the note and the
note said
um hi it's the owners you've been locked
out of our property now and you will get
your stuff back but call us to arrange
pickup so the squatter called us and he
was so angry he was saying that he'd
been locked out he was calling us as if
it was like a Holiday Inn hotel and the
key card wasn't working to his property
it was it was just mind-blowing
unfortunately you've got no rights
you've got no rights
that place
no damage whatsoever unsecured
he was an interesting chap you know I
think he was like he kept on calling so
many times
um he kind of
he just we've actually got the
conversation like he was starting to be
a bit inappropriate with Leah Remini
take me home for the meal baby
compensation
and then he started asking me how old I
was and it was just getting really
inappropriate and
um he started saying that if I saw him
in real life I'd never you know I'd
never guess that he's a squatter he told
me he had a beautiful blue eyes and I
thought he said beautiful thighs like
about his legs and I was like why is he
telling me this
the amount of people say about my eyes
go far from
okay are you married I am
coming it's early days
yeah
all right then I'm gonna have to go okay
oh oh I'll think about you tomorrow
okay we'll beat you in a bit all right
everyone says Michael you laugh on me
come on all right bye-bye
bye bye bye bye
so today's the big day today is the big
day not the big big day that's later in
the year yeah today's the biggest day of
the year until our wedding day that's
our next big day look at all the Foodies
left we have to Chuck all that away
I'll put my gloves on in a minute and
I'm going to start because then mice
will be here this is oh that's his
mattress okay this is where he was
living
plugged in it plugged in a TV in that
and his kettle
all right no worries
compensation
don't worry about compensation
um I really appreciate that and thank
you very much and speak to you soon
I actually felt quite sorry for him and
like from a human perspective I kind of
leveled with him a little bit and people
in the comments were just going crazy
they were just like what is wrong with
you but from a human perspective like I
can see where he's coming from but
actually what he's doing ironically is
stopping us from creating 10 more rooms
for 10 more people in the area so yes
it's off position like at the end of the
day you've got to be pretty
to break into a former nursing home and
set up your
Camp there